[Music]
foreign
Steven Crowder Stephen Crowder
despicable Guy Stephen Crowder who shall
be referred to as Stephen cowada not
only is he extremely misogynistic and
sexist he's also homophobic he's a
disgusting garbage human being he's been
his brand from the very beginning just
go look at the titles of that guy's
videos like he's like the king of like
saying
horrible offenses there's something
going on with the problem I fully
believe this is a man that is on such a
spiral it is just shocking to me that
any person cannot see exactly what he is
right now
and remember I have not offered a word
on any of it
you want something to change it starts
with love
it starts with love for the truth
but love without truth is meaningless a
love based on a lie is just that
to lie
I've seen all the attacks the media
against Stephen is because they're
scared the art and ideological war we
are in a potential Tipping Point in this
country you need different kinds of
people you need different battalions
it is time to match intensity
that shows you how up this
country is like I don't buy it's all
money this case needs to be blown up the
ATF needs to be held accountable
why can we not condemn evil Behavior
[Music]
a single one of you watching or
listening right now needs to flip a
switch in your head where you will make
those sons of embarrassed that
they ever even thought of asking that
compliment